At Hillsdale, you’re taught how to think.
You’re taught how to meet challenges and
exceed them and wait for the next challenge.
That has helped me my entire career.
That chance to just spend four years immersed
in learning and becoming a better human and
to focus on the soul and the body—it’s
irreplaceable.
I got involved in the Collegian very early
and from there it confirmed that I wanted
to get into journalism, so I spent the next
four years—outside of my tenure in Washington
with WHIP—focused mostly on the Collegian.
Collegian sort-of became the focal point of
debate about what Hillsdale was going to be.
Those relationships that were forged have
been lifelong relationships.
We had people who were just amazingly great
at their fields.
They were brilliant, they were world-renowned
in Political Science and History, and yet
they wanted to teach; they wanted to be with
us; they want to make us better.
I had no clue where I was going to go.
I just wanted to go out and cover stories
and write and then got into editing.
I started at the bottom.
From there, I kind-of got opportunity after
opportunity.
It was just kind-of serendipity.
That led to my job at the AP where I was deputy
business editor and then the business editor.
They cover the world.
There’s nothing like being at the AP when
a big story breaks.
And then out of the blue I get a phone call.
I met with Delta’s Chief Executive Officer
then and the President—and the President
is now the CEO—he said, "Listen Kevin,
you’re a great storyteller and we need to
improve storytelling at Delta.
But most importantly, your values fit ours.
And at Delta, values are the most important
thing and how we treat people."
Two years in, it is the key reason why Delta
is considered the best airline in the world.
Did I ever think I’d be here?
No.
But I never thought I really was anywhere.
My career has just sort-of gone from place
to place.
I’ve been blessed.
Grigor sent me an email and I open it up and
it says "Congratulations, you’re going
to be awarded."
And I literally laughed because this is the
last thing I ever thought.
I’m undeserving of the award.
I’ve had a good career and just thrilled
and totally honored to get this recognition.
It means a ton to me.
I can’t sit here and say specifically, "Oh,
I am where I am because of Hillsdale."
But I am.